plot four comma negative one and select
the quadrant in which the point lies
so for the first number in our ordered
pair that's our x coordinate that says
how far to move in the in the horizontal
or the x direction it's a positive 4 so
i'm going to go 4 to the right and then
the second coordinate says what do we do
in the vertical direction or in the y
direction it's a negative 1. since it's
negative we're going to go down and it's
a negative 1 so we're going to go down
1. so that right over there is the point
four comma negative one so i've plotted
it but now i have to select which
quadrant the point lies in and this is
just a naming convention this is the
first quadrant this is the second
quadrant this is the third quadrant and
this is the fourth quadrant so the point
lies in the fourth quadrant quadrant
four
and i guess you have to know your roman
numerals a little bit to know that
that's the that's representing quadrant
four
let's do a couple more of these
plot eight comma negative four and
select the quadrant in which the point
lies well my x coordinate is eight so i
move eight or i go eight in the positive
x direction and then my y coordinate is
negative four so i go four
down
and this is sitting again in no not the
first not the second not the third but
the fourth quadrant in quadrant four
let's do one more of these hopefully we
get a different quadrant so we want to
plot the point negative five comma five
so now my x coordinate is negative it's
negative five so i'm going to move to
the left in the x direction so i go to
negative five and my y coordinate is
positive so i go up five
so negative five
comma five and this is sitting not in
the first quadrant but the second
quadrant and of course this is the third
and the fourth so this is sitting in the
second
quadrant
check answer and we got it right